what's going on guys it's a screen
junkies team doing the ALS challenge we
were challenged by Nick Mundy and a lot
of our fans on Twitter and Facebook
thank you for that and it's Nick thanks
Nick you've never beaten the rock again
oh I'm Hal Rudnick I'm Dan Moreau I'm
Andy signor and we are challenging first
I'm gonna challenge my surrogate family
mama June and honey boo boo I'm
nominating everybody's favorite wookie
Chewbacca and I'm not making the Billy
Zabka okay Johnny from the credit kid
and sensei Chris Martin boom all right
what's that a little more ice to
everybody the water is freezing
one two three
rolling up my pants did nothing